hey leute guckt euch hallo hallo
[Musik]
willkommen beim ein video wir sind
gerade für ein land auch im kino auf
einer tollen javidan als preview von
kings man auf jeden fall wollte ich
eigentlich das video morgen drehen wir
haben bei dem mega hunger und deswegen
habe ich spontan gedacht ich habe nicht
nur eine kamera dabei fangen jetzt ja
ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich anbietet
schon gelesen entschuldigung für die
schlechte kamera qualität gerade haben
wir hier überhaupt geparkt ich glaube es
nicht
nein haben wir nicht vor ungefähr
eineinhalb wochen kam ein video welches
fahrstuhl reform hat die besten chicken
nuggets und ihr habt euch ganz klar für
pizza entschieden also heute geht es
halt und pizza und pizza ist auf
geradezu mein favourit wenn ich jetzt
entscheiden müsste was ich essen will
würde ich sofort pizza wählen wir wollen
jetzt sofort ziemlich richtig
ihr wollt wir wollen jetzt sofort hier
aus der innenstadt von pizza hut und
fondo - also ich achte schon darauf dass
es die pizzerien also das ist die fast
überall in deutschland österreich und
schweiz gibt also wirklich niemand kennt
damit er mit dem video auch was anfangen
könnt und da das video von der qualität
her nicht die ganze zeit so scheiße
bleibt kurz erklärt wir fahren jetzt
superzahl und zu dominos und danach
gucken wir mal welche pizzerien ist noch
gibt ich habe mir überlegt vielleicht
noch eine tief geführt damit als
vergleich zu nehmen und dann wird das
ein sehr qualitatives video mit wirklich
fehlt lerninhalt und dann scheißt auf
schule weil alex wie pizza das ist viel
wichtiger
jetzt so leute wir sind jetzt endlich
wieder so weit meine erkältung wieder
richtig besser auf jeden fall sind wir
zu hause wir haben jetzt zum einen schon
mal die pizza von pizza also dass hier
spitze hat und das hier ist miley und
ich habe es gerade noch eine pizza über
lieferanten bestellt die solche moment
wir haben 15 jedem band da sign and i
haben einfach schon um 15 und ich habe
schon gesagt ich habe noch überlegt wird
man heute von einem überraschungs ein
video alles was ich nicht gegessen habe
ich einfach hier oben hingelegt
eingefroren haben wir nehmen nur eine
eine tiefkühl pizza salami als vergleich
zu hier stechen den ofen rein und dann
fangen schon mal an fläche denn
probieren wir das gleiche andere pizza
kommt weil das dauert ungefähr 20
minuten und ich habe mittlerweile noch
mehr hunger an sich ist eben schon hatte
was ja auf jeden fall alle mal fleisch
machen solltet was sie als nächstes
getestet werden wenn es pizza schon
gemacht wie ein türke nackig gemacht was
haltet ihr euch nach diesem video auch
auf jeden fall anschauen und es gibt
jedoch mega viele andere dinge zb sich
jetzt immer mega bock auf wenn ihr
darauf auch bock habt und schreibt auf
jeden fall mal heftig eis oder so
einfach in die kommentare
dann sehe ich das ja und ja also der
pizza liefern wie man sieht sollte jedem
moment kommen
wir warten jetzt einfach mal
ihre pizza bestätigt mir das lustige war
dies schon angekommen bevor wir
überhaupt hier zu hause waren und der
typ muss nun warten deswegen mussten wir
uns jetzt irgendwas wichtiges einfallen
lassen damit es noch einigermaßen witzig
wird und unten war so eine
fahrradfahrerin die dachte sich auch
alter da will jemand einbrechen
wo soll jetzt machen wir noch kurz für
die tiefkühlpizza liebt meine name luigi
machen gute pizza ja erst mal kurz doch
die alle camp und dann fange an soweit
herzlich willkommen hier im offiziellen
alex wie pizza testen studio wie schon
gesagt was mein ist wir haben ja einmal
danke sagen wir haben gerne und hier
haben wir eine x-beliebige pizzeria die
man eigentlich nirgendwo findet auch der
welt ausleihen können wie ich hier
nochmal media media pizza also keine
kette wir werden auch das sehen auch
hier die ketten besser abschneidet als
die media plätze und die tiefkühlpizza
ist halt noch im ofen ja ich will gar
nicht lange da angefangen sofort mal an
und ich würde sagen gefangen an mit
smiley pizza guck mal ich muss dir das
leisten als nur hat die anderen plätze
durch hass habe ich daran zu setzen
heute wäre mir eine smiley pizza salami
das ding hat sechs euro 70 gekostet wir
hatten hier warte mal 123456 stückchen
dh 76 für so eine kleine pizza
ich würde mal sagen es ist noch ok aber
schon relativ teuer oder das denkst bei
dieser ich weiß schon wie die schmeckt
aber ich probiere es normal also ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin ziemlich
erkältet und weil ich so erkältet bin
schmecke ich nicht wirklich aber ich
kann sagen dass ich mir gute pizza
obwohl sie gab es mehr so ganz frisches
ich meine ich das bestimmt schon die ist
auf jeden fall noch lauwarm schmecke
jemand hammer also ich bin ja wirklich
so 0 der kritiker da haben wir ja einen
kritiker hinter der kamera sitzen
deswegen ich bewerte es positiv ich
würde jetzt wirklichen achtgeben zu
echtem super dingen und wenn du dir
jetzt die auch noch im warmen vorstellst
einen traum so deutschland erst noch ein
bisschen applaus zu meinem mitbewohner
pizza kritiker lobby recht kritisch wenn
ich stück hast du noch nicht
eingesammelt hat mussten schreibt mal
alle hersteller gute besserung gar nicht
in die kommentare danke finde ich jetzt
gar nicht gut findet sie nicht nur was
wenn du nicht mehr ware dann müsst ihr
euer ganz auf essen erstmal halten
abgebissen oder wieder zurückgeworfen
aber keine ahnung also würdest du jetzt
was wir zu sagen jetzt kommt button
lassen sich lassend chip branche jetzt
sagt ich sagte leider kein foto wissen
so weit will man sagen wir gehen jetzt
von der kette zum wie ist sie noch
einmal media media pizza also ich habe
jetzt eine gute und eine schlechte
nachricht die gute nachricht ist die
haben echt früh geliefert also das ging
ziemlich schnell die schlecht ist das
ding ist gar nicht geschnitten
gruppenanfragen geschrieben ist ja eine
frechheit also leute jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt wie das hier so schmeckt
irgendwie schmeckt sorgt der einbrecher
nach pizza aber auf der anderen seite
falls sie also das ist so eine richtige
pizza auch immer sich die vorstellung
und ich sofort gesagt richtig gerne
pizza bestellt sich irgendwo eine pizza
die kommt an und schlägt einfach nicht
also ich würde jetzt natürlich auch
essen nur im vergleich zu dieser jetzt
ist es auf jeden fall keine acht mehr
sondern mehr seine vier rafinha mehr so
der liebe kritiker deswegen gebe ich nur
5 das ist eine lieb gemeinte 5 und das
teil hat ebenfalls 76 gekostet es ist
vielleicht über ein ganz kleines
bisschen größer wurde eigentlich ist
genau gleich muss also beide sind genau
gleich groß waren genau gleich teuer und
da diese pizza hier von smileys
eindeutig gewonnen acht punkte 5 punkte
aber wenn ich sie eigentlich so anguckt
sieht das von der seite schon länger aus
ja dann weiß man die ist 1000-mal besser
als die der nähe ich will ja nee is
tausendmal besser als dieser ihm ist
trocken ich bin diese hier eindeutig
besser deswegen weil ich auch noch mal
die schmeckt viel besser war ja was
sagst du wie viele punkte er gebe ich
den 6 was ich mich frage eine pizza die
zehn grundsatz von mir bekommen sich
gold drauf oder annähern außerdem
sollten niemand vor dem bewertung geben
wir dass sich dann niemals verbessern
mit
sorry leute aber ich muss noch mal ganz
kurz eine ganz kleine werbeunterbrechung
einfügen oder wie auch immer auf jeden
fall weiß nicht ob jetzt schon
mitbekommen habt dieses magazin das
nennt sich herr staeck screenshot dass
es jetzt auf dem markt ich bin auch mit
einem großen artikel darin das könnt ihr
über kauf von jedem kiosk das coole
daran ist alle youtuber und in pflanzen
aber sonst muss ich ja dran sind haben
den artikel komplett selber geschrieben
deswegen jetzt lohnt sich lediglich also
wenn ihr gerne liest als auch noch genug
an mal quatsch drin dem man sich mal
durchlesen kann braucht auf jeden fall
also ich hatte auch mehr spaß daran
trägt dass mal ab und es war heute so
nehme ich aktiv gruppen die wissen was
sein ist mein absoluter favorit ist
pizza hut ich bin das so hofft man sieht
gar nicht mehr also als er noch kein
automatisches nicht jedesmal forschung
zu gestiegen bin nach hause gefahren bin
bei pizza hut vorbei am hauptbahnhof
habe mir jetzt meine schöne fette pizza
mitgenommen deswegen hoffe ich jetzt
noch mal die haupt mich mega hier vom
hocker was man aber auch dazu sagen muss
es kommt auf die filiale an also die im
hauptbahnhof in köln
falls ihr das seht ihr seid die geilsten
also ich muss wirklich sagen ich muss
doch mal kurz probiert aber ich glaube
das ist mein favorit heute also das ist
wirklich eine mega gerne pizza leute ich
kann euch nur sagen das ist kein flächen
und ich dafür kein geld aber wenn teure
umgehung pizza isst dann gehts sitze hat
so jetzt geht wieder kritisiert aber ich
weiß schon dass so etwas nicht noch
kritisiert die können sogar 10 389 damit
sie sich weiter hin verwischen
[Musik]
falls ich weiter entschieden jetzt immer
machen
das ist irgendwie so woran liegt das
dass gott die menschen können
ich weiß nicht du kannst bei denen ja so
auch auswählen so mit dummen rand alles
so volker schmeckt es stimmt ich habe
viele punkte verträgt ich gebe gerne 92
58 58
aber was musst du dich jetzt von oben
drauf kommen das ist eine 10 ist ein
bisschen andere salami käse nicht zu
verpacken
die verpackung bisschen schöner hansson
wunsch die verpackung ein bisschen
schöner ja auf jeden fall können wir
auch nicht mehr machen das ist noch
keine zehn würde so leute ungefähr
wieder waren jetzt drin pressestunde
ich habe es irgendwie gar nicht
verstanden die ist einfach nicht fair zu
bereuen
auf jeden fall haben wir jetzt noch eine
tiefkühlpizza eigentlich muss ich auch
so eine bezahlen wenn man sie schneidet
oder absolut was man bei hitze hat auf
jeden fall auch ergänzen muss die pizza
hut nur sechs euro gekostet und ist
damit günstiger ist die anderen beiden
also wird gespart 70 cent
ahadi ist auf jeden fall heiß ich kann
schon mal sagen 173 gekostet ist damit
am günstigsten ist ja auch logisch ihr
könnt ja meine kommentare schreibt ich
finde aber eine tiefkühlpizza schmeckt
irgendwie anders nach pizza allzu allzu
14 ja irgendwo frisch gemacht werden
also ich finde da gab es wirklich einen
unterschied oder wie siehst du das
absolut schönes wir voll und ganz zu ja
besser kritiker okay leute schlägt auf
jeden fall okay wenn ich jetzt mit den
anderen plätzen vergleiche das ist auf
jeden fall der vierte platz aber wenn
man was leckeres essen möchte dann ist
sowas natürlich voll cool aber ich denke
bist ja auch alle mini-tief gemüse
schmeckt ja ich will das einfach mit
vier gegen vier punkte juli waren es
noch warte ab stücke machen das ja heute
das war dass alex ibiza experiment fast
food duell test wie auch immer schreib
auf jeden fall verstecken die kommentare
wenn
das ganze wird eis machen sollte also
kingston mc sunday alle möglichen
fastfood eis die es so gibt es gibt es
wahrscheinlich in der woche wurden zwei
wochen keine ahnung wir sehen uns
freitag wieder freitag um 14 uhr bei 10
vielleicht kommt es dann sofort stecken
also nächste woche oder übernächste
woche wir sind uns da am freitag wieder
auf jetzt nur jackson instagram auf
jeden fall folgen haut rein